PhD student in conversational
neuroscience and today I really want to
talk about the topic of studying during
your free time so I have to go to my PhD
from about nine to five every day and
there I do General tasks such as giving
lectures doing programming etc etc but
actually during my free time I love to
learn about new topics as well and so
for me I spent almost around at least
one hour to two hours every day to work
on this YouTube channel and to work on
different type of creative Pursuits
outside of my PhD and today I really
wanted to give you some tools tricks
techniques such that you can also
hopefully study a topic that's outside
of your main job because I think for me
at least it gives so much energy for my
main Pursuit which is my PhD to study
something else on the side because
actually if you have this kind of
balance in your life between two things
that you really enjoy I think both of
them can kind of intertwine and give
energy towards each other so I think the
most common challenge that all of us
face when trying to study during our
every time is energy and I noticed at
least for myself that a lot of times I
just don't have enough energy to push
myself towards studying and this is
really a bottleneck so usually I do have
for example one or two hours in the
evening that I could spend on studying
or learning a new topic but when I try
to push myself towards that I notice
that it's actually really hard to get
myself motivated so today I want to give
you some tricks that I've learned over
the years to kind of get over this first
hump and to kind of get into the flow of
studying some topics that do actually
give me energy once I'm finally studying
them so the first tip I want to give is
to optimize for your curiosity type so
one of the books I'm reading lately is
curious minds and that's by Perry zern
and Danny Bassett and Danny Bassett is
actually this professor in computational
neuroscience and I really like the work
that they are doing so if you are
interested I would definitely recommend
looking up their work as well but they
talk about three types of curiosity now
people usually have or that people
usually follow follow when looking at
curiosity so the first type they argue
is the busybody so the busybody makes it
their business to know about everything
and anything they want to know as much
as possible and like a butterfly flit
about from topic to topic the second
type is the hunter so conversely the
hunter has this super focused curiosity
and they tirelessly track down their
discoveries like a hound and the last
type is the downside so the dancer
leaves creatively true knowledge relying
on their imagination and in the book
they dive way deep into these three
different archetypes within curiosity
they also say these archetypes are not
necessarily fixed within any one person
so it could be that you're one day a
little bit more a busybody or a hunter
and the next day a little bit more a
dancer but I do think most of us have a
preferred style and I know for me I'm
very much the dancer type I would say
it's more that I like to flit from topic
to topic and kinda combine them together
in a creative way but when I really deep
dive into a topic I usually get bored
quite fast so I like more at the
beginning of a learning process like
seeing how I can combine different
topics and really thinking about how I
could creatively link these two whereas
I know for example I think my professor
is a little bit more a hunter and he
really clamps down on one question and
then searches for the answer of that
question for days and I think if you
think about your curiosity type and you
try to think in your life how you can
actually lean into that type instead of
trying to to force yourself down into
another type you will actually find that
you have so much more energy for
studying different types of topics at
the end of the day so after you've
decided what kind of type of curiosity
you have I think it's nice to think
about intentional defaults so
intentional defaults is a topic I think
I learned from the channel from Ali
abdal but it's something I've been
thinking a lot about lately in my life
so intentional defaults are the default
behavior that you would do in a certain
space for example or a certain time of
day so what I I'm trying to do lately is
every time I come home from uni
immediately I start doing something for
the YouTube channel and that can be
anything it can be or writing in scripts
or making a thumbnail or learning a new
type of editing technique but because
this is my intentional default when I
come home and also when I sit in this
space it kind of is ingrained in my
memory or in my behavior to do that
every time after I come home and I think
by having this intentional default of
working on the YouTube channel at a set
time and a set place it really allows me
without too much friction to work on
these goals that I have and work on this
new type of curiosity that I want to
explore without really having to force
it down on myself and the last topic I
want to talk about is input versus
output girls so output goals are the
goals that most of us think of when we
think of goals so for example for
self-studying it would be something like
I will know how to edit or I will make a
perfect YouTube video or I know how to
do all I will get an A on my exam for
mathematics whereas like input goals are
actually the input you put into your
goals so it's for example every day I
try to work on the YouTube channel for
one hour and I think when I think of
course input goals are a lot easier to
optimize for in that sense also to get
some kind of reward from so when I look
throughout my life I usually try to
focus on input goals and not so much
output goals this output goals per
definition are kind of outside of our
locus of control whereas input goals are
really what we can ourselves put into a
certain topic so yeah these were just
three really short tips that I wanted to
give you and I mostly want to push you
towards reading this book because I'm
highly enjoying it and if you know your
curiosity type I would actually be
curious to know what it is so put it
down in the comments below and otherwise
see you next week bye